I wonder if you're taking into account
like the financial level and income
because yeah guess what even if you're a
single parent household if you have a
let's say your mom has a lot of money or
your dad has a lot of money chances are
you're going to be a lot better than a
two parent okay do you know what's so
crazy but you keep going back to this
where money is better than I'm talking
about westerns tonight no but even in a
western Society yeah you know like why
is why is a money better than a father
because that's what that's what it is at
the end of the day it's never a single
father home it's almost always a single
mother home